this is a production of cornell
university
so um just to start i want to orient you
a little bit about where i'm from this
is washington state in the middle there
washington is a pretty diverse place
it's not just green rainy seattle
this is a landscape
shaped by volcanoes glaciers and ice age
floods so it's really a pretty
interesting place to drive around and
get out if you like to do that kind of
thing
this is
where we are in the middle here in
wenatchee
we're about halfway roughly between
seattle and spokane
yakima the tri-cities hood river below
us are kind of the other major centers
of the fruit industry in washington
state and then portland is down a little
bit closer to hood river there on the
bottom
so the the
primary areas where tree fruit are
produced in washington are pretty close
to the columbia river
in this area this shaded area roughly
and so some of these areas are up the
river valleys and
all of this all of the tree fruit in
washington is irrigated and so the
location of where these orchards are is
really because of access to water
ag is a big part of of washington's
economy particularly eastern washington
the gray counties here are the the top
10 as it were this is um i think 19 2010
data from the washington department of
agriculture
and and apples for probably 10 15 years
have been the largest value farm gate
value within the state
they passed wheat and and continued to
increase
a little bit small print up on the left
there but
one thing i want to point out here is
that of the about eight billion dollars
in farm gate in 2010 about half of that
is horticulture crops within the state
it's not just fruit
fruit
nursery greenhouse
there's there's a quite a diverse
industry there's there's bulb production
up in whatcom and skagit counties as
well
but we're going to talk about apples
today this this is the wenatchee valley
this picture actually i got from januk
lee who some of you
know
and wenatchee on the the um
this side of the river east went at you
on this side
this is the columbia going through town
this is a springtime photo you see the
lupine and the arrowroot balsam root
blooming here everything's really nice
and green
pretty spectacular time of year for us
but
as the summer goes on it's it's
basically a desert
where we live
and which which has some really big
advantages for growing fruit because the
humidities are low
there is access to water for irrigation
and so there's there's really low
disease pressure relative to a lot of
other places that grow the same crops
that are grown there
so it has some some advantages in that
way
another thing that's that's a little bit
curious about the wenatchee area in
particular
you'll go back here
is the
difference in elevation from the river
level up into some of these benches that
are around town which is
about
about roughly about 2 000 meters
indifference
which which means for something like
sweet cherries you have
the same cultivars that are grown
within a probably a 10-mile radius that
get harvested
over a month
just because of the difference in bloom
dates because of the elevation
so
a little bit of the
the uniqueness of that
a little bit about about apples in in
washington this is this is obviously the
biggest
single crop
this year is the biggest volume crop
that they've ever had 120 million boxes
almost two and a half million tons of
fruit
which so far has been relatively easy to
market because of what happened to you
all last spring
there's quite a bit of nervousness about
what happens over the next few years
but
you know a lot of different cultivars
delicious is still the the biggest one
by volume but that's down almost 20
percent in the last
15 20 years or so
which makes it actually easier to market
everything because there's just
there's more diversity
people don't get held hostage to all the
volume and delicious that the buyers
know they have
so
that's a lot of apples and
the big reason why there's that many
apples part of it is because there's a
world market that can
that has the demand but also it's
because of post harvest technology i
think we post harvest sites like the
claim
and i mean apple biology lends itself to
having ripening manipulation
be
ripening extended by storage in in
controlled atmospheres
particularly low oxygen
the low oxygen component and so there's
there's um
installations like this
in a lot of places in eastern washington
where you have these just massive rooms
that hold anywhere from 800 to 3000 of
these bins which hold roughly 20 to 25
um boxes 40 pound boxes equivalent of
apples
and so a lot of what what we do is is
really related to
how can you
optimize the system such that you can
have maximum flexibility for marketing
over an extended period and so this is
really an integra in a integral part of
being able to to deal with this gigantic
crop
one of the the keys to making
ca work is to
put the right
um the right thing in it
and that's really a key keyed to
fruit maturity at the time when it's
harvested
i mean ca is a fantastic technology but
it works best when you have fruit that's
at the right stage of development when
it goes into into storage
and
so
physiologically there's i think those of
us that work on apples
would say that there's a a point in the
development where fruit is optimum for
its long-term storage and that's related
to the onset of of the ethylene
climactic
but from a horticultural perspective and
from an industry perspective
that point in development doesn't always
match with what the conditions in the
field have provided you with any any one
season
so for example this is a a
series of pictures of honeycrisp
harvested over a
number of weeks
and what the trade wants is something
over here right because they're red this
is what they can get paid more money for
but you know there's times when the
biology says this is what you should be
doing
and so there's this compromise that
happens
within the industry to to balance those
two parts of of the equation
and early harvest you know if the
color's right if the fruit looks good
and it's at a point where the biology is
right great but that doesn't always
happen
so if you end up having to pick later
then there are some
issues that
the warehouse goes through to determine
how long can we hold these things and
and for a lot of varieties that's based
on how firm they are
and typically you're going to have a bit
of a shorter storage life as you move
across that range of development
now i want to talk about a specific
example of this here
um
predicated a bit by the the two types of
maturity physiological
which means that the fruit will ripen
after you pick it
it won't just shrivel up and and sit
there i mean apples are climactic they
go through a specific series of
of events that makes them get right
as opposed to horticultural maturity
which
certainly for a red apple
is dependent on how red it is what's it
look like
and
sometimes you these don't match up and
so you're you're really waiting until
you get to what's going to make you
money
as opposed to what you can store the
longest period of time
and for delicious in particular over the
last really 100 years there's been a a
selection process
where material has been vegetatively
selected because of how red it is
and it it's
being redder being better
as far as a marketability standpoint
goes but it's not just redder it's also
when it's getting red
and so if we look at an older cultivar
starkin versus a newer one scarlet spur
the newer ones tend to get redder
earlier in the year and really what that
translates into
from an internal qualities perspective
is that they're they're redder at an
earlier point in development
so that they're they're harder or more
firm at a point where the trade will say
these are these are what we want color
wise and this is why the strains of
delicious that are produced commercially
now are are not starking because if you
wait until you get to the color
level where you could be profitable
they're they're too soft you can't store
them
and so over the years
there's virtually none of these produced
commercially anymore in the northwest
it's all these newer newer strains
so now on on to the the volatile part of
this
so apple volatiles like
it is for other fruit that has aroma as
one of its quality components
um really are are one of the the key
components to
differentiating flavor and aroma among
different cultivars
and
within a cultivar this process of
generating ripening related
volatile compounds is developmentally
regulated um ethylene is is required for
this to happen
um and so it's it's very important at
the maturity at which the fruit is
harvested
is really important in how well the
fruit can execute this this ripening
related part of its its program
and also the environment in which the
fruit is stored has a big impact on the
ability of fruit to produce these
compounds and so those are those are
some of the things that i want to talk
about for the rest of my my presentation
here
i'm going to use
three different examples
related to the maturation process
then um the impacts of one mcp one
methylcyclopropane
on this process
as well as as storage and then also the
last part is going to be some work that
we've done relatively recently
looking at
volatile accumulation during storage
rather than
after storage when the fruit have are
taken out and and let to sit um at
ambient conditions
a little bit about the the analysis that
we use typically the the work that i've
been involved in
and that i'm going to talk about today
is all based on sampling from intact
apples
um
part of the reason we've done this is
there's there's kind of been an
overriding objective
to
develop some sort of um
quality assessment that the the trade
could use
and
seemingly the easiest way to do that for
them would be to be able to do this on
intact fruit the other reason is that
when you when you cut apples or or
apples in particular
there's a whole nother series of
compounds that tend to get produced
and so since we're interested primarily
in in fresh fruit
we've we've stayed with this kind of a
system for most of the work that we've
done
and and what we do is we put apples into
jars and let them equilibrate for a
period of time with a flowing air stream
through them
and then we we collect
the compounds that are coming off the
fruit on a
absorbent
polymer
in a glass trap
that is then
analyzed using gcms
using the system and this is this is a
pretty efficient process
there are some compromises that are made
based on the phase or the the material
that's used in this these traps but this
one 10x is actually
pretty um pre has a pretty broad
spectrum of
absorptivity absorptivity
and the way that we do quantification
based on um
settings using standards
based on the same system gives us a way
to do good quantification of what we get
in these samples
so um to start with with maturity here a
little bit of background as i mentioned
maturity is really important
in determining the capacity of of apples
to produce ripening related volatiles
after harvest this this is uh some um
data from a a paper by song and banger
published in the 90s and and basically
what it's showing here with this was
with gold malicious is that
as harvest occurs later in the season
you go from
a
fruit that's really pretty unable to
produce a lot of compounds related to
aroma
to an increasing capacity
as
both initially
at the point of harvest and then after
harvest
one of the a couple of the key things
here are that in in the first harvest
here where they're they're getting
substantial production you see that the
peak in that production is occurring
relatively later than it is in the later
harvests
and so what's happened here is that the
fruit is matured and then started to
ripen on the tree it starts to have more
of a capacity to produce these compounds
but as as you pick later and later
it the production maximizes and then
actually falls off sooner
as it compared to the later ones and so
this is one of the things that that
contributes to post-harvest quality of
apple fruit in relation to maturity
because if you pick earlier you get a
longer storage life but you have an
inherently less capacity to produce a
lot of these compounds just because of
the point in development of which it's
been picked
and so with with that as background
um we were interested in in this problem
or this issue specifically in relation
to delicious cultivar
because delicious is is an apple that
gets picked relatively early
in its its maturation and ripening
development because it gets soft and so
if you pick it relatively late the
storage life is compromised quite
considerably and so what we were
interested to do was to look at the
really the seasonal variability
in
things that are normally measured in
relation to maturity as well as the
capacity to produce
ripening related volatiles at the point
of harvest to see how how consistent or
or inconsistent that was
on a year-to-year basis we use this
strain red
bisbee delicious which is um
somewhere in the middle between starking
and scarlet spur ii there aren't very
many of these around anymore either
because they don't get this red as early
in development compared to something
like scarlet spur
so um
three of the the maturity
components that were we measured were
internal ethylene
concentration
starch score
with a visual rating using a potassium
iodide solution and then also firmness
from a from an industry perspective they
don't typically have this information
this is not something that
most warehouses generate on their own
so they're relying basically on on has
it what's the color here and then what
are these two values telling us about
how how mature how ripe are these fruit
if if we are going to assume that
the fruit is fully mature physiological
mature physiologically mature when it
reaches uh internal ethylene
concentration of one microliter per
liter
and that for long-term ca the optimal
starch
is just over two on a one to six scale
and that the firmness is just above 70
newtons
then these are the things that the
warehouse would look at at the point of
receiving and then make the decision as
to whether or not this goes into short
medium
long-term storage i mean basically how
what are we going to do with this fruit
to maximize our marketing flexibility
and so um in the four years of of
the study that i'm reporting here
there was quite a range a three week
range of a bloom date this is the same
trees same block
um over four different years
and um
i think there you know in all of the
years
ethylene started to be produced starch
scores went up and the fruit got
less firm
but when you compare across the years
there's there's some
differences that are
relatively important in determining the
post-harvest fade if you will of these
fruit
so for example in in the first two years
um the ethylene patterns are relatively
similar a bit higher in the in the first
year
by the last harvest
the the starches were up into the higher
twos or above three
the firmness at the point where the
start the starch was two was still
it was still above 70. so these are good
candidates for long-term ca storage um
before the end this this is one of the
things to keep in mind here is the last
two points
in all these years
when when we get into the last two
you see a couple things is that
relatively earlier in
the the harvest period
the firmness has dropped below 70
and in this year the starch went up
quite rapidly above that the point of um
acceptability for long-term ca
as opposed to last year when it was only
at the last harvest when it was was that
high
but what would happen here if you wanted
to say picking this year for long-term
ca
you're going to have to pick pretty
early starch was going to be low and and
likely these fruit were not going to be
red enough and so basically what's
happening would have happened is they
would have had to pick later
and and not put them into long-term ca
so um
the analysis of of the volatiles that
were being produced and this is not
including ethylene this is the other
things that are the fruit are producing
a
principle components analysis here that
accounted for just under 70 percent of
the variability you see that we've got
nice patterns related to the four years
of the study
the red one is the late bloom year
which
will make more sense when we get a
little bit further on here in the
presentation but one of the things i
want to point out is that in all of the
years the
the data is pretty well clustered around
the same points
early in the development period
and and one of the the real
differentiating factors between the
years is as you get closer to the the
later harvest dates where things are are
a little bit more different than they
are earlier
and um the loadings plot for the same
data really this is driven by
the onset of production of a lot of
ripening related esters
that tend to cluster in the top of this
plot the things down in in the lower
areas tend to be
alcohols
aldehydes there's a few esters in there
but really once once right maturity
physiological maturity has been attained
and ripening starts and the fruit starts
making esters that's really what
separates out
the data set
so this is this is
all the things we measured here
same arrangement same bloom dates across
this way the the plots at the the
five things at the top here
are growing degree days
this is starch ethylene
hours below
and then the incidence of or the
severity of superficial scald after six
months in storage because scald is
related to maturity at harvest
in in most years and so what what what
you see as you look across this this
plot is that in all of the years the
biggest change in volatile production
was at the last two harvest dates
and it was really relatively abrupt
where
not much was happening before we got
until these last two harvest aids
in in the year where the harvest or the
bloom was relatively later
there there was quite a different
profile
in a number of compounds which tend to
be
alcohols aldehydes which serve as
precursors for ester production
you know i don't have an explanation for
why this happened other than this
happened in a year where the fruit
really had a relatively
less days on the tree
and and it was also
its initial stages of development was
during a period of year where the
environmental conditions were were
somewhat different than they would have
been
when bloom was earlier i mean these
these are components of
um say yearly variability in in
production of these things that aren't
really very well understood because it's
it's difficult to do this kind of
research but so that i guess one of the
messages here is that these patterns are
not consistent from year to year in some
aspects
even even this the last two
harvest dates being the point at which
there was the biggest change in
volatile production
if you think back to the previous slide
there was the the other things that we
were measuring ethylene production
starch and firmness didn't necessarily
follow that same consistent pattern and
so so what's happened here
is um a couple things oh let me step
back here a second the
the the group within this cluster
which um you can't really see it as well
on here as as i can see it here
tends to have less of a change over this
period of time
compared to
um the bottom ones these are a group of
ethyl
esters
which um as you let delicious fruits sit
out in the bench and get ripe these tend
to
increase a bit later
than some of the other compounds do
and those being this the group in the
bottom two clusters here which tend to
be um
have a different alcohol moiety in the
ester butyl hexopropyl pentyl and then
two methyl butyl acetate and these
compounds you can make
if you take a bunch of these and make a
mix of of the pure standards you can
make something that smells pretty much
like a
you know a nice ripe red delicious apple
so these these tend to be produced in
volume relatively earlier
in the ripening process
than the ethyl group does
as as a comparison
so
you know what that said to us is that
like the other components of maturity
that we measure
this process is a little bit different
every year as well
and and when you think about how this
happened over the four years in relation
to the other components of of
physiological and horticultural maturity
this increase came after the point of
horticultural maturity in some years and
before it in others so when it comes
after
what that means is that this fruit is
off the tree before it reaches this
stage and it's not going to have the
capacity to produce a lot of these
things
meaning that they're going to taste
different
even though they may look the same as
they did the year before and it's one of
the things that makes delicious
have some people question that part of
its name
so next this is um
the impacts of of one mcp really the
influence of ethylene on this process
as well as
part of what storage does to the
capacity of fruit to produce these
compounds so for this part of the study
we used gala
they were treated with one mcp um
very amazing inhibitor of of ethylene
action
um highly used in the commercial trade
around the world anymore
and and then um they were stored either
in air or in a controlled atmosphere
at one
kilopascal oxygen and two co2 which is
pretty standard for the the industry in
the pacific northwest
so these these fruit were held in
storage and then we took them out and
let them sit for a week at 20 degrees
which is kind of a standard
simulation of transit and retail
for apples after they come out of
storage to see how it would impact
components of quality including
production of volatiles
so that there were a number of
treatments this is actually kind of old
data when we were trying to look at you
know how much mcp
is enough as it were and so we went from
0.1 to 10 microliters per liter
of 1mcp at harvest and then stored in
air or in ca
ca alone or
with
a treatment of mcp prior to going into
storage
relatively early in the storage
period taken out every month for seven
months you see this differential really
even at one month
there's a difference relatable to the
fruit having
been treated with one mcp prior to
storage
and as that as the storage periods
extends you know basically these things
really aren't changing very much
the the blue circles and the purple ones
are the fruit that have been stored in
ca
after about four months
the group treated with mcp but then
stored in air
starts to change a bit and does
differentiate between the ca as but
still is higher than the untreated fruit
and the lowest
mcp treatment and it's similar for
titratable acidity which is another
component of quality that's important
for
for
flavor and aroma not not aroma certainly
for flavor
so
a
loading's plot of the volatile results
from this
and you see on the left the the
treatments progress up and out in the
plot
with the concentration of mcp and then
at the top the combination treatment
mcpca or ca alone
and and what tracks over here is
the bottom group here
um again is primarily
acyl esters
that are really give the the fruity
components that the ones that are
produced relatively earlier in ripening
for for gala and as you go up and then
um into the sea area
ca area these again this there's a lot
of these ethyl group ones that are are
present up here and really what this is
showing is that these tend to be made
much more in volume
in related to these treatments than to
the
mcp or the the ca ones
so um
esters alone
as under over the same period
the controls in the lowest mcp treatment
which didn't do much for firmness or
acid
you see we had this initial increase and
then another increase later in storage
the later increase was also
also happened in the fruit that had been
treated with the higher rates of of one
mcp
either group stored in ca stayed
relatively low
at the longest storage durations
compared to the other mcp treatments
so this this this
biphasic pattern if you will is a bit
unusual
and when we went in to look at what
individual compounds were doing
in relation to this pattern um
you see that uh in the initial period
for the controls and the lowest rate of
of one mcp that there's production of a
number of compounds that is is higher
than it is in in
the treated fruit
and what these are again is this the
series of of relatively um
these simple acyl esters that don't
include the ethyl ones
and and so then when when you look at
the
five to seven month period where we
started to see an increase in a lot of
these other compounds
within the the checks and the low mcp
treatment we also saw that in all of the
mcp treated fruit
but
we didn't see
this group alone
once the mcp treated fruit started to
have the capacity to produce these
compounds
and so
what what appears to have happened here
is that the treatment with one mcp
didn't just delay
the onset or the the production of a lot
of these compounds it really changed the
pattern of how they were produced such
that you miss this initial period where
you're really only getting these these
real fruity
more characteristic group of compounds
such that when the fruit regains the
capacity to produce these it's a
different suite of compounds if you will
compared to this initial period
and so you know why this is happening
specifically is is something that um
remains to be
determined but it you know it's not a
simple
well the fruit is old it's starting to
get
senescent
or overripe however you want to describe
it because
these fruit
could be classified that way they're
soft they're low acid but these aren't i
mean these are still firm they still
have a lot of acid
and so what it means is that this this
whole process has been
um
altered by
having ethylene
action removed from the equation as it
were for a period of time such that it
doesn't really recover
the capacity to ripen normally i mean
they're getting ripe and they're doing
things that that galas do during that
process but it's not the same pattern
that you see in the controls
um
yeah again that's when the second
pattern
second production is this ethyl group
again along with a number of
aldehydes so it's a different group of
compounds as opposed to the one on the
bottom
so i think what this illustrates is
you know mcp's having a big effect on
this
um
in the trade
gals aren't stored for
a period of time such that they would
experience this increase in air because
if you're going to store them for a long
period they're going to be this they're
going to be the ones that are in ca
so what does that mean about what
they're going to you know what are they
going to taste like when you put them in
your mouth
and it turns out that's not as simple of
a
question as you might think it is
this is some work that
gene kupperman colleague of ours at wsu
and
anna marin from oregon state university
really were the drivers behind this a
few years ago and what they were the
question they wanted to ask is how do
people perceive
one mcp treated fruit versus non-treated
fruit
that have been um
where you've selected using a
non-destructive firmness technique so
that firmness is pretty much the same
it's not like you're taking controls
that haven't been treated that are soft
and comparing them with treated fruit
that are still hard these are all about
the same firmness
we did the volatile analysis for a
number of key compounds and
i hope you can see this that the bold
columns on the right which are the ca or
fruit stored in air that haven't been
treated are all significantly higher
than the fruit that have been treated
with one mcp and then stored either in
air or in ca but
what the folks they gave these two to
test and they basically said
can you you have a preference and what
is your preference
was was pretty interesting to me in that
when you look at the mean liking scores
for all of these groups
mcp air versus control ca mcpca control
ca or mcpca versus new crop fruit from
chile that hadn't been stored
these these scores are all pretty
similar
and um
the
the preference scores
in general favor the fruit that have
been treated with one mcp
so what does that mean it means that
people's preferences for apple flavor
are different you know it's not just a
matter of saying
you've got a lot of these they're going
to be better well some people may that
may be why they thought these were
better but it's not that simple
and so i this there's there's been a lot
of work like this done trying to sort
this out with with mcp on apples and
other crops and it really i think
depends on the questions that you're
asking i mean if you want to
say
that mcp makes something
better or worse you can do that by the
way you set up these consumer type tests
or even taste panel with with trained
panels
so it's not as simple of a question as
more is better and i think the other
part of that is that
as if you if you think about
the differential and production of
different groups of of esters as
ripening progresses
as the fruit starts to get older and
into the phase where it's producing a
lot of ethyl esters they don't taste the
same i mean that changes how the fruit
tastes
um when you combine that with softening
more may not be better in that that
instance as far as as
how that impacts quality
so on to the last part and this is
volatile production during ca storage it
turns out that
there's not a lot of literature about
what happens while fruit is stored in
low oxygen
or high co2 controlled atmospheres most
of the work like this has been done
as i described earlier where it's taken
out it's let's sit for a while to
simulate
shelf life as it were and then you do
the analysis so we've been interested
the last few years
to try to develop information that
provides additional
management tools as it were to industry
to
make determinations about fruit quality
and marketability while it's still in
storage and so one of the things that we
started to do was to
set up experiments where we would
actually do the volatile measurements
while the fruit was still in ca
and
for for this group of stuff we we picked
two situations
where um
the environments were set up so that
they would cause problems but the first
one being
low oxygen where we went down to 0.3
kilopascals oxygen to try to generate
low oxygen injury
the reason you would actually
try to operate that way commercially is
to try to prevent this disorder
superficial scald which low oxygen can
be a way to at least delay
and the other one is high co2 injury of
fuji
which develops this really wonderful
internal browning with
cavities
that when you look at the fruit you
can't see that it has it
so
this this
the way we collected the samples for
this is we have our our chambers our
research scale chambers they hold about
eight of these
fiber trays of fruit
and
same collection system here's our 10x
trap
a little pump where we would we would
circulate the atmosphere from this these
chambers onto the traps and then we
could
basically do the analysis on the traps
the same as i described earlier
and that way we don't have to take the
fruit out we're not changing the
atmosphere it's it's staying under the
low oxygen or high co2 conditions while
we're doing the sampling this is the
the ports on the side of the chambers to
to get the gas in and out
so for for the delicious part of this
i just want to briefly show you we've
done this for three years now and
the the first two years of this the
fruit was relatively similar starch-wise
a bit higher in ethylene
the first year
all three years the firmness was pretty
consistent the last year the the fruit
was had much higher ethylene the starch
scores were higher the acidity was lower
so these these are more these are fully
mature and started to ripen i think a
bit more than the first two years are
all from the same orchard
manage the same
so
the low oxygen
concentration on the left the amount of
time and storage on the right and these
are not equivalent periods as you go
down the
the
axis here they're they're weighted
towards the front end
such that these are all about a week
apart and then it starts to get longer
so
what we saw relatively early on in the
lowest oxygen concentration
was
an accumulation of of compounds that we
weren't seeing
as we increase the oxygen or
as we were storing fruit in air
and guess what these were again it's
this whole series
of ethyl esters including ethanol so not
surprisingly
apples make esters really largely based
on the alcohols that are present so if
you have a lot of ethanol there
you tend to get
these ethyl esters earlier than you
would if um in this case because these
these apples are not ripe
two weeks after after harvest
the um then there's there's other groups
where
the changes are not as affected
really other than the ca compared to the
air air fruit
and then there's a whole group down here
which are again a lot of the early
ripening related compounds that are
being produced
much more in the fruit stored in air
than they are in the ones in any of the
ca environments and really one of one of
the things that regardless of low oxygen
concentration these tend to be produced
less which i think you know if you eat
fruit that comes out of ca you
inherently know that there's there's a
lot less production or you know you just
don't taste these as much as you would
if you're eating a ripe one that's never
been in that same condition so low
oxygen has this effect as it does with
with galas
the the different atmospheres did a a
predictable job of managing firmness and
acidity
the the lower letters here are the
differences within months
so that the cas are higher
all of the ca treatments are higher than
the fruit stored in air it was only at
eight months where the lowest oxygen in
this
experiment was higher than the other two
so
you know again we're we're restricting
part of the ripening process here by by
these treatments but the oxygen the
differential in oxygen is having a
pretty big impact on what the fruit are
are making
so
one of our objectives here is okay can
we use
measurement of a fewer of these
to provide some indication that there's
an issue or not an issue
and quantitatively
as as you might expect ethanol ethyl
acetate are the the compounds being
produced the most
um this is in in one year of the study
all of this day i'm sorry was from 2011.
and so if you're going to try to use one
or two values or compounds to try to
make this assessment
you either need to have a pattern that's
different consistently or you need to
have a threshold value above which you
would say there's a problem
so
here's the
the
the
lines the slope of the line of
accumulation in the first week
clearly
much more rapid in the lowest oxygen
than
the fruit stored in air or the other
oxygens
but if we look at
the amounts
in this year
the only treatment that got above 10
nanomoles per liter was the lowest
oxygen and for ethyl acetate um
somewhere between four and six
so maybe though maybe that's a range
where if you're going to try to do this
commercially you could you could say
this is what we want well we've done
this for three years and
in two of the years the patterns have
been relatively similar
these two where we saw this initial
rapid a relatively rapid rise
and it continued to get go up for you
know within the first three months
the kicker is is this one
where
this fruit at 0.2 was
was anaerobic it had plenty of ethanol
but it didn't accumulate very well
until almost three months in storage
and so if you're using you know we have
to use
if we're using 10
we're not going to know there's a
problem until we get out to here
and that's going to maybe be too late to
do something about it within the room
that's what this
line is is in um in this in this year
once
one of these groups that was stored at
0.3 got up above 10 we raised the oxygen
to 1.2 and you see that over time
the
both for ethanol and for ethyl acetate
well not actually not as well here
the values start to go back down meaning
that the fruit can recover once you put
enough oxygen back into the room
the other
issue here is that as opposed to
the
other year when we use 0.3
where 0.8 percent
never induced enough ethanol to get up
but above 10
it did in this year
so i think
you know this is this is only three
this is three seasons with one lot so
when you think about this in relation to
a whole room full of fruit from
different lots
setting a threshold value to try to do
this might be more difficult than you
would think
as you think about the biology of fruit
and why this happens in the first place
so i think that was one of the the
messages or the lessons that we got of
the stuff from delicious
for fuji
only the fruits start at five
kilopascals co2 got co2 injury
okay
so there's there's a large group here
where
relatively little difference between
the treatments
and this is the fruity
stuff that tends to get produced
relatively early there's no ethyl
esters in there
when we look into
this cluster
ethyl esters and some methyl esters as
well so even at
high co2 is is causing a differential
production of a bunch of these compounds
as opposed to the fruit that are stored
in air
um
i think one of the issues here again
okay
what could we pick that might tell us
there's a problem is a bit more
difficult because the the quantitative
relationships between these treatments
aren't really very different
um
and
here's ethanol over here and you see
that this doesn't increase to its
maximum until pretty far this is six
months into storage here
and so um
maybe not surprisingly we didn't see
that happen
but when you look at what production of
a few of these did
some of them um ethyl butyrate
methylbutyrate early on there was an
increase
in all of these but but the treatment
differential five to one and a half to a
half
you know that's not a big enough
difference i think if this was something
you would see consistently to be able to
say
this much is telling you have a problem
and what we see over with ethanol is
that fuji's just inherently make ethanol
pretty well
and so i think what happens early on
is they can pretty efficiently take this
and make it into esters
and so
we're not seeing as much of an
accumulation early as we do late when
this capacity to produce ethanol
continues to be there whereas the
capacity to produce epster's with it
actually decreases the longer the
fruit's been in ca
so that's probably part of the reason
why we're getting this this accumulation
later in storage
so um i think that's that's where i want
to stop and
um i guess the the things that that
we've taken home ourselves over the
years is that you know harvest date
season are really important and it's
it's important in ways differently for
different cultivars just because of the
way different cultivars mature and ripen
before they're ready to be picked
ethylene action is is is critical to
this process
control atmosphere has effects even
within
the different
gases manipulations
that we do
and really it comes down to biology
for what the fruit is going to do
and the business having to make
decisions based on what the biology has
already done
and i think that's the challenge for the
industry and in what they do every year
so um these are the folks that that did
all this work dave and janie are
technicians
luis and and jutong were post-docs
christie is a master student who just
finished and dave riddell is
one of our colleagues
in the lab so
thank you
for the mcp actually for the
the controls it wasn't it it never
really dipped as much as the
um ester production did it was it was a
really i mean that i think that's the
only time i've seen that biphasic
pattern and and so we've you know we've
done some um we're actually repeating
this again this year to see if we get
that so there wasn't as much of a change
but in the mcp treated fruit stored in
air that's when we saw ethylene start to
be produced again
yeah
gosh i'd have to go back and and look at
that that people there's a lot more in
that paper than that that table but you
know they were very careful
um to
try to minimize the impact of firmness
here
and you know these this acoustical
method for doing this
i think a lot of people would argue is i
mean it's
you you can
you have to use that value with a little
bit of of understanding that
it's measuring something
but
if you get groups that have the same
value i think
my personal opinion is that you can
still tell differences because the
texture isn't necessarily the same
between those
and so that
that's part of what
people were looking at here and this was
this was consumers these were people at
the portland sunday or the portland
farmers market is where they went and
did this so it's not trained panelists
it's just people who like apples
people i think um that plot is from
people who who eat a lot of galas in
fact so even within that population
there were people that
said you know we like these even though
it's not making this these other
compounds
i think that
my experience certainly has been that
mcp
and or ca
really don't impact
sugar as much as they do other parts of
ripening
and you know that it's it's really
determined at the point of harvest how
much starch is there that's going to get
broken down i mean ethylene action
doesn't appear to have much of an effect
once the starch degradation process has
started it pretty much just goes
and and so there's less of an impact on
on sugar
as opposed to a lot of the other things
and so
one of the reasons that i have acidity
on there and for the gala example is
that
before mcp was ever around
um one thing that we had noticed is that
because in part of the impact that
maturity assessment for red delicious
and it's offset from the capacity to
produce volatiles
putting that into long-term ca
where even if they could produce
volatiles at harvest it's not going to
be very efficient after they come out of
ca
that acidity becomes a relatively more
important component of quality because
when it gets too low
and that number is different depending
on the on the cultivar
you know fruit just don't have much
going for and so you better have acid
left at the end
because you don't have much of these
other things
and i think you know when when you look
at
the changes in
sugar as a as opposed to harvest it
actually goes up a little bit because
starch is being metabolized but
as a percentage change
acidity the acidity change is
considerably higher than it is for sugar
as as fruit ripens and it sits in
storage
there is and it's it's different for
different cultivars
um in part because
not everything
inhibiting ethylene action isn't 100
positive for all cultivars
you know we can argue that it's not
positive for aroma production
but it also in some cultivars that are
sensitive to co2 it actually
extends the period over which they
can have issues if they're exposed to
co2 and so for fuji for example where
we're from
you don't want to treat them right away
when they're harvested
because
it makes it more likely that you're
going to have co2 injury as opposed to
something like gala or delicious
which
have where firmness management is much
more of an issue so you want to treat
them as soon as you can after harvest
because then it has the maximum impact
on preserving firmness and minimizing
firmness loss
the longer you wait the less of an
effect typically that you see but
one of the first experiments that we
ever did was in march
with fuji's that we got from a warehouse
and
we treated them and then we let them sit
out and
we could detect differences even that
late in the year i mean it wasn't
something that would have been
commercially significant
but
you know ethylene is important
throughout that process
at least for some components and so
if you interrupt the ethylene activity
there are things that happen even
relatively late
um in our example with with fuji's
so um
one mcp is a gas for for those of you
who don't know and so the
the the current license holder
has developed a formulation that can be
field applied which seems you know as a
kind of a technological achievement at
least some you know
and and
whether or not there are
um impacts related to disorders from
pre-harvest treatments
i'm not sure
that that's been very well characterized
i mean i haven't been involved in a lot
of that work i don't know have you guys
seen anything
related to har vista and and disorders
actually i take that back
um
jennifer diel
has has seen and actually we've seen
this too now i think about it that um
some of the honey crisp disorders can
actually be less
if the fruit has been treated with mcp
in the field and it tends to be
those that are
they're chilling disorders but they're
related to maturity
and so i think what's happening is that
when you um treat them in the field it's
slowing down maturation
and so it's prolonging the period where
they're not as sensitive
to low temperature um this this you know
i think there's a lot more work that
needs to be done in that area but um
because one right now one of the things
that
the commercial business is trying to do
is to minimize the post-harvest effect
of this material because they don't want
to jeopardize their post-harvest
business
but um i think there's a lot of
opportunities for that for for different
reasons other than just
disorder management that remains to be
seen
at this point
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu
you